Michael Vaughn sees himself as a
Statesman of cricket
but this former England Captain is
charged with bringing the sport he's
acclaimed by into disrepute
used as a cricket disciplinary hearing
of racially abusing Yorkshire teammates
in 2009
on the day four players of Asian
Heritage played for the county for the
first time
the England and Wales Cricket Board case
is in this moment Vaughn told them
there's too many of you lot but Vaughn
was read discriminatory tweets from 2010
referring to directory inquiries he
wrote why when you ring 118118 are all
the people who answer foreign can't make
head or tails of what they are saying
annoying these tweets resurfaced after
azimrafiq exposed the Race's culture
while playing at Yorkshire sparking this
case
rafik has apologized in the past himself
for anti-semitic traits and Vaughn at
this hearing repeated his regret for
offensive posts but TCB lawyer Jane
Mulcahy QC said the tweets were
lighthearted but offensive and put it to
Vaughn the tweets are remarkably similar
in tone to the allegation
Vaughn disagreed Michael Vaughan
believes this case has become far too
public he believes that Cricket has
handled the situation badly and he sees
it as a terrible look for the game
but Yorkshire have already admitted
there was systemic use of racist or
discriminatory language while Rafiq
played there
and other former players including
Matthew Hoggard are not contesting the
charges
Michael Vaughn denies wrongdoing and the
hearings are set to conclude next week
Rob Harris Sky News Central London